what up peeps
it is march 11th 2021 i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report
direct message live from los angeles
although i can't say sunny los angeles
because it's hailing outside right now
that's right we are in
the midst of uh at least one of the ten
plagues i'm pretty sure there's a couple
others
going on was homelessness one of the 10
plagues was rampant drug use
and horrible traffic and roads that are
crumbling or any of those
uh part of the ten commandments because
we're in the midst of it right now and i
think god
is sending a message to our dear leader
gavin newsom who's being recalled people
it's pretty
spectacular over 2 million signatures we
only needed
1.5 and in 5 days from now 3 16
2021 that was the last date to get all
the signatures things are looking good
i'm feeling good about it we're going to
talk about that in just a moment
uh as always just a quick reminder to
click that subscribe
button and that notification bell so you
see our videos and as you know we are
live
five days a week at 11 a.m pacific
which it's 11 a.m pacific right now so
that the proof's in the pudding people
uh we are doing a q a right now uh from
our reuben report locals
community we got over 200 questions i
think so we just grabbed whatever we
could i did a
quick scan of them and we got some
politics we got some lifestyle we got
some fun stuff
some silly stuff we'll get to all of
that uh i did want to do one story
up top before we get to it because as
you guys probably know
the jury selection for the george floyd
trial of the trials actually obviously
for the police officer accused of
murdering
george floyd um is happening right now
i was actually on newsmac this newsmax
this morning with
alan dershowitz who's obviously the
harvard law professor and one of the
most esteemed legal experts
in the country talking about the
specifics of the trial and one of the
interesting thing that
happened is that attorney general keith
ellison who is
a really far left sort of crazed
progressive who you may remember had
once put a picture up on twitter with an
antifa book
so this is a guy he's telling you what
he believes he's now the attorney
general
of uh of minnesota and he actually was
almost
the head of the democratic national
party he got he missed it by like two or
three votes or something
um but in essence he now is going for a
third degree murder charge
and what's happening is you can sort of
see that this whole thing is being set
up
so he's going to get acquitted basically
of third degree murder because
third-degree murder without getting too
much into all of the specifics but you
should do a little googling on your own
in essence third degree murder is like
if you drove your car intentionally
into a crowd of people to kill a lot of
people or you started firing into a
crowd
intentionally just maiming people first
degree and second degree that's probably
what's more applicable in this
but keith ellison is throwing that third
degree charge in there
in a way in my estimation at least
because he wants riots and he knows that
this will make it harder to convict
and thus when he doesn't get convicted
of all of the things even if he gets
convicted
of first degree and second degree murder
which probably will happen if he doesn't
get
convicted of third degree that will be
the excuse for the violence and it is my
belief
at this point that the progressive wing
of the democratic party
wants violence they want there to be
mayhem
those are their foot soldiers so i saw
this video
yesterday and we thought it was worth
playing and then we'll get into as many
questions as possible there is an
autonomous zone remember the autonomous
zone
up in seattle where laws don't apply and
people are
not allowed in unless the autonomous
zone people let you in and people get
murdered there and a whole bunch of bad
stuff
well they've got one now in minion and
minneapolis
let's take a look this area behind me uh
is the george floyd memorial this is
where george floyd
was killed back in may take a look these
bay arcades have been set up
by uh by protesters and supporters of
the movement
uh they don't allow anyone in not even
the police it's called an
autonomous zone uh and
it's very tense near the memorial and a
militant style group has closed off
several blocks with barricades
all right so that video is from news
nation now and let's just be clear
about something those two people that
are
wandering around the autonomous zone
pretending that they're kings or
whatever they are
they should be arrested and anyone there
that is in there that is taking over a
street not letting police officers not
letting police officers i mean how does
that even make sense even that
that very statement that police aren't
allowed there
like this is stuff that happens in third
world countries that are run by
gangsters this is not stuff that is
supposed to happen
in the united states of america that is
happening in minneapolis
in minnesota right now and we just sort
of sit there and we watch and we go
oh i guess that's kind of okay so
already keith ellison the attorney
general
of minnesota he already is in
dereliction of duties in
in my humble opinion and i suppose
probably in legal opinion
as well right like he should be sending
his police in there
and saying to these people well we're
arresting you because you can't just set
up
your own autonomous zones you can't just
set up your own places with your own
laws
in a city in the united states of
america but i don't think progressives
really believe in law and order right
well they'll believe in it once they put
everybody away in the gulags and then
you know they
silence everybody else but in essence we
are already saying the laws of the
united states don't matter that's what's
happening
in minneapolis right now it ain't good
and i think you're gonna see but
clip this video even my haters that are
watching this and i know you're there
from media matters and vox and daily
beasts and you're just waiting for me to
say something
but you can clip out of context uh mark
my words
that when he gets acquitted of the third
degree murder situation
that there is going to be mass violence
and that's exactly what keith ellison
wants that
that is my belief i hope i hope and pray
to god that i'm wrong
i really do because i don't want
political violence unlike most of you
people
but that's the situation that we find
ourselves in all right guys before we
get to the q a
i want to talk to you guys about raycon
as you guys know about once a year i
like to go off the grid for the month of
august it is once a year actually
but as you can imagine unplugging is
easier said than done and what about the
other
11 months of the year i still need my
time away from screens and devices as
you know i try not to tweet on the
weekends
fortunately by putting in my new raycon
wireless earbuds i have found a way to
reset my eyes without missing the
important content i need
to do my job and live my best life
whether you're catching up on reuben
report episodes listening to the
audiobook version of
don't burn this book which i read myself
or powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist a pair of rakons in
your ears
can make all the difference these things
are seriously
super super clear with no dangling wires
or stems raycons come in a range of
stylish colors
and always with a comfortable in-ear fit
for a more discreet look
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction and bluetooth
that pairs quickly and seamlessly
and with enough battery life for six
hours of playtime you can unplug for a
while
the best part raycon makes great sound
accessible to everyone with wireless
earbuds
starting at half the price of other
premium audio brands that's right
they're cheaper than apple earbuds
raycon is offering 15 off all of their
products for my listeners and here's
what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com slash ruben
that's it you'll get 15 percent off your
entire recon order
so feel free to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15
off at by raycon r-a-y-c-o-n.com
reuben by raycon.com reuben and now back
to me all right guys so we got a ton
of questions i told my guys to mix it up
i did a quick scan but i haven't even
read all these we're doing them on the
fly
so here we go jeremy says what is your
prediction for the timing
of when the mainstream media and the
left turns on president biden
and forces him to resign to resign this
is a great question because
you know i've been saying how you know
if you watch youtube shows if you're on
twitter if you listen to podcasts it's
like basically
everybody knows something is severely
wrong with joe biden
and as i always preface every time i
talk about this
i take no pleasure in that but there is
something obviously cognitively wrong
with the
president of the united states at this
point i would argue and i think anyone
sensible would argue it's probably a
national security threat
at this point right he often doesn't
know where he is he forgot the name of
the defense secretary the other day then
he forgot the defense secretary works at
the pentagon
what do you call that that outfit over
there he mumbles through a lot of things
he mixes up words sometimes he's not
he's not sure where he is all of this
stuff okay so
it's a massive massive scandal except we
seem unable to talk about it because
they won't talk about it on cnn or
anywhere
mainstream why is the new york times why
has nobody written anything
anywhere yet so if you're one of the
blue anon people right you're just
sort of a blue pilled person that only
pays attention to mainstream you may not
know it you may not
see it because if you're not online you
wouldn't see all of these clips that go
viral so then we have this reality war
where some people see reality as it is
because they see these clips and then
some people only see the filtered
version that gets to them through
mainstream media
so i think there's two things here
there's two ways that this can basically
go down
either he's gonna have like a sort of
full
breakdown publicly where you know the
teleprompter goes out
and he just genuinely has no idea where
he is or what he's doing and it's by the
way gotten pretty close to that i mean
the other day when he forgot the name of
the pentagon and and his defense
secretary you know he's reading off a
teleprompter it's not like they just let
him go out there and talk so
you know if if the prompter breaks down
or he can't read it or whatever it is
something
is going to happen where it will become
so obvious that then people will have to
step
in but actually i think this second one
is the one that will be uh probably more
realistic in terms of happening
or probably will happen first i would
say which is that the pressure
will become too much to bear for someone
in on the conspiracy right because
everyone knows it dr jill biden knows it
she is basically abusing her husband at
this point barack obama knows it hillary
clinton knows it
all of the staff knows it and they all
know it and they're all keeping a secret
and the thing is you cannot keep a
secret like that for too long
because as it starts leaking out more
and more and as their friends and family
i'm talking about the staffers and all
that say hey is something wrong with the
president how's your boss like
something's up
like somebody will start leaking it and
then once it starts leaking because
someone's going to want to get ahead of
the story
right because my guess is actually
people will end up in jail like this is
a scandal this is a true scandal
um that that basically people will want
to get ahead of the story they will want
to be like hey i was the one trying to
tell people you know there was something
wrong with the guy
and you know we had to do something so i
will break the story and then they'll
write something in the washington post
or something or they'll be interviewed
by by somebody probably tucker carlson
on fox news or something like that
so i don't know how long it's gonna last
my guess is this can't go on probably
much more than six months from now
but you know the machines got away the
swamp's got a way of protecting its own
and they can hide him and he still
hasn't done a press conference
and he didn't do a state of the union
and all that stuff so so we shall see
lance says if trump runs in 2024 do you
believe desantis is the running mate
or abbott of texas my gut feeling is
trump is done running
i think he probably is enjoying life
right now
you know one of the things he's been
doing he's been kicked off twitter so he
can't tweet
but he's been releasing these very very
short sort of twitter style press
releases that then people
pick up and put on twitter it would
actually be hilarious i mean
if i was trump at this point if trump
don if you're watching
i would be you should be releasing 10
press releases a day
just like treat press releases fully
like twitter and just have regular
people
just be promoting your stuff on twitter
all day long are they going to kick
everybody off twitter
maybe they will i mean honestly maybe
they will um but
i suspect that trump likes the sort of
outsider think i
i think in a certain way he's better
suited
to be an outsider and i discussed this
the other day but if you take a guy like
desantis who i would vote to be
president in no
time right i would love for this guy to
run okay not only i think he's got the
right ideas and didn't destroy
florida in the midst of the pandemic i
think he's 48 or 49 years old we need
some young blood in there
he's shown that he's willing to stand up
to the system but is he willing to go
all the way and fight them the way trump
did that takes a a particular
type of firebrand it takes a particular
type of wiring and i don't think
everyone has that
so what to me trump should be doing
is i'll be the bad guy i will fight all
the fights so that you guys can be
somewhat respectable because
you know a ton of people a ton of people
that i know personally and and comment
sections and emails and everything else
would always say you know i've really
come around on trump on the policy stuff
and i get he's fighting the meeting a
lot but it's just it's just the
personality stuff it's
it's the grabbing by the [ __ ] it's all
that stuff that i can't get over
so if trump can sort of act like the bad
guy which he's already framed to be and
then help
some of the quote-unquote more
respectable people get in that
that seems better the one thing i could
maybe see him doing and i mentioned this
the other day someone said this to me in
florida
was uh that trump could maybe run for
governor of
florida have ron desantis then run for
president that maybe seems like
something but i suspect he's probably
just gonna do it from the outside
uh kathleen says with all the changes at
disney plus regarding dumbo peter pan
aristocats
etc do you think that disney will now
require donald duck
to wear pants great question kathleen
you know yesterday we covered this story
how
uh disney a few months ago it didn't it
didn't get uncovered to the last few
days but they moved dumbo peter pan
aristocats which yesterday on the show i
called aristocrats which is a very very
different movie
than aristocats and swiss family
robinson they move them from the
children's section on disney plus
to the adult section which is just crazy
at so many levels it's not censorship it
has nothing to do with the first
amendment
but just like this idea that a child
shouldn't be able to select dumbo
because they're going to see the birds
and then suddenly become racist i mean
it's just
completely idiotic uh but your question
do you think disney will now require
donald duck to wear pets i mean
i know you're being funny but like
they're going to come
for everything um i was getting an
illegal haircut this morning
my girl may even be in my house right
now hopefully the stormtroopers don't
show up and knock down the door while
i'm on air
um and my girl said to me she said well
what about miss piggy because miss piggy
was basically sexually accosting and
physically abusing
uh kermit the frog all the time right
kermit wasn't really into piggy
piggy was beating the crap out of him
she beat the crap out of a lot of people
you know i'm pretty sure she raped him
at some point like there was definitely
something going down there we didn't see
it all on
on air but like you know they've got to
come for
everything what whatever it is you love
you love the show cheers in the 80s you
love the show the jeffersons
in the 70s you loved whatever whatever
it is you loved
friends or full house or whatever show
came out yesterday
this thing is here to destroy everything
and i
you know a few people have been saying
this online but i i have come around to
this
get physical copies of things because
just wait till they just start deleting
all sorts of things and deleting
people's apple accounts and deleting
your cloud storage
and all the movies you've bought and
everything else it's kind of funny like
we all had a friend that had like a huge
dvd collection and it's like what do you
have all that crap for
that guy's gonna be sitting on a pile of
gold once they start getting rid of
everything else
freedom fan says who's your favorite
founding father
and why you know i've mentioned this a
couple of times but i would say thomas
jefferson
and i there's arguments to be made for
all the founding fathers
in many ways i think my my personal
preference
to tj is that when i was a kid i was
probably about 11
12 years old we went to monticello that
was his home
in virginia and it's an it's a
phenomenal estate and they give you a
tour obviously and you see
uh you know his bedroom and his writing
room and just the just the
the full uh the full estate and how
wonderful it is and and just
it's and it's also just gorgeous there
um so i had like this attachment to
thomas jefferson when i was a kid i've
been there many many times probably
about eight times
over the years and you know when they
give the tour they talk about the
complexities of a man
that was a slave owner also writing the
laws that freed the slave
they don't deny that he most likely had
relations
with at least one slave which
by modern definition i mean you can't
own a person thankfully but
if you were to own a person and have sex
with them that would be raped by modern
standards
but we're all just people of our time
that's not an excuse for anything it
just is what it is but they address it
very honestly and forthrightly they show
you his desk like his writing desk which
is just really great
and there's just something about because
i've been around it as a kid like it
just sort of like got into me about
thomas jefferson and i would say the
other thing about thomas jefferson
is that if you're ever allowed to go to
dc again i know it's like a military
compound right now
and there's just nobody on the streets
there and you may remember i was there
what about two months ago yeah i was
there in december
and i did a video with kyle kashuv
walking around dc and it was deeply
depressing because you only saw
homeless people on the streets and this
was before the january 6 incident where
now they've just put barbed wire
everywhere and fencing everywhere and
everything else
but if you ever make it back to our
nation's capital
uh the jefferson memorial which is a
little off the beaten path you know
everyone goes to the lincoln memorial
they go to
uh the washington memorial they go to
the uh all of the
all of the main stuff that's in just the
main mall there with the with the water
and everything
but the jefferson war is a little off
the beaten path and it's
just spectacular it's just spectacular
you know obviously they've got the big
concrete version of of jefferson but
they've got some of his writing on the
wall
i've posted it on twitter a couple years
ago it's just great uh anya says it
looks like there will be a recall of
gavin newsom
what do you think the actual chances are
of electing someone better so this
is the million dollar question the
recall is going to happen
short of the deeply corrupt democratic
machine here in california just
eliminating thousands
hundreds of thousands actually hundreds
of thousands of votes right because as i
said before
we now know we have over 200 000 there's
been an independent audit where they're
saying over 1.8 million of those
check out we only needed 1.5 we've still
got five days
to keep getting more votes people have
had it with him uh
you may remember the other day on the
show i read this tweet from uh
foolish old socialist bernie sanders
who's saying that this is this is
radical right-wingers that are doing
this and
no it's regular people who want to go
back to work and go back to their
restaurants and go back to the gym and
all of that it's people who are mugged
by progressive reality you old buffoon
so look the my guess is the recall
happens but your question is
the actual chances of electing someone
better so this is where
california i don't know i always say
maybe it's just the nice weather
although it's hailing
out today that people are sort of
fried mentally here and they don't seem
to realize that they keep voting in the
very people who raise their taxes and
who destroy
the education system and who increase
the levels of homelessness and drug use
on the streets and all those things so
my hope is some good people will run my
hope is maybe adam corolla runs my hope
is rick grinnell runs
are they electable i don't know but i
would at this point
short of like an uh an out and out like
a vowed communist
i think anyone would be better than
gavin newsom he is the exact type
of entitled millionaire politician who
must
go away he's like andrew cuomo you gotta
go home now
actually you don't got to go home but
you can't stay here you got to get out
of here
uh farah says when you have kids will
you homeschool them
um so as you guys know we are working on
kids i mentioned a few weeks ago
that our our surrogate did have a
miscarriage it's it's a
whole process life works in in weird
ways obviously
um but we are we have started the
process again i don't want to talk about
it too much now because i don't want to
get
uh put the the cart ahead of the horse
here um
but will will we homeschool them well i
can promise you this there is no way in
high hell that i will send them to
public school or even private school
here in california
my feeling is we got to recall this guy
and if we don't then maybe i just got to
get going but i want to stay here and
fight as long as i can and when we did
our live
meetup for our locals community last
week we had about 100 people at a bar in
l.a
everybody was begging me to stay i will
not raise kids here around this lunacy i
just simply won't i would why would i
bring a child into this world to be
brainwashed
to believe all of the things that are
completely against the things that i
believe
and the things that i fight for so um if
that's not to say that there aren't
any decent private schools and charter
schools here in la there are a couple
most of them are religious based
but i think homeschooling is becoming
more and more of
a norm that makes sense to a lot of
people because you know
i wrote about this in dolby in this book
but one of the last things that allowed
me to say hey i am still a liberal i'm
still an old-school liberals that i did
believe
that there was some role for the state
in public education but now that it has
been
wholly infected by the disease
the mind virus that is social justice i
just don't believe that anymore
so i think we probably would homeschool
them or my hope is that there will just
be more and more charter schools and
small schools popping up all over the
country
and that that will be a better way
because i don't you know i'm on a show
here i can't have children screaming all
day
in the house uh jay petes says with the
onset
of daily wire jumping into entertainment
and the creation of social media tech
like locals
could we be seeing a subtle shift back
to some kind of balance
or has sanity lost its foothold forever
so first off
what the daily wire is doing by creating
movies now
actual content going in a direction like
netflix is
phenomenal candace owens is launching a
new live talk show live studio audience
talk show old school
sally jesse rafael style uh in i think
next week or
in two weeks or so i'm sure i'll be a
guest on at some point i can't wait to
get down to nashville and just do a show
with live people and candace is
wonderful and
i have no doubt she'll be a great
gracious host um so they're going into
not only movies you know they brought
gina carano on after the whole
ridiculousness at disney plus that we
referenced before
um so they're going to make movies
they're going to make more talk shows
live studios all of those things
then there are tech companies like
locals where we're building
the tech so that you guys so that
everybody everybody has the tools to get
off big tech if you are sitting only on
youtube and twitter and facebook
and you don't have some off-ramps and
you don't own some of your stuff have a
server in your house or have backup
of your stuff or or if you're a creator
of any kind and you don't own
your audience uh information contact
information if you don't own
your data you know if you just if you're
just a regular youtube creator and the
only
you edit your stuff and then you upload
it to youtube and you're using that as
storage
you're going to be screwed one day so i
think that there are a lot of reasons
to be hopeful for the future because
people are building things it still
ain't going to be easy there's problems
with amazon servers
there's problems with the apple app
store and google play store and all of
those things like we know all of those
things exist
but i believe in the human mind i just
fundamentally believe in the human mind
brian savage says it's aristocats yes i
addressed that earlier i called it
aristocrats
which is a very funny movie but very
different than aristic hats
sonoma lady says since the governor shut
everything down because he had emergency
powers and now that there isn't any
emergency because as everyone sees the
numbers have dropped like a rock
why isn't everything opening back up
this is a great
question sonoma lady and uh you
mentioned emergency powers can we put up
an image
of emperor palpatine and as you remember
emperor palpatine what happened what did
emperor palpatine do well i've got
the exact quote here because you know
after he got into that incident with
mace windu and the whole shebang
he said in this very uh image here that
what he was saying was in order
to ensure the security and continuing
stability of the republic we will be
reorganized into the first
galactic empire the reason i mention all
of this
is because once politicians have
power they want more power that's why
the star wars prequels are good because
it's all about
accumulation of power you create a war
you create a crisis you create
a pandemic and then you get more power
our wonderful politicians now with this
1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief bill that has almost
nothing to do with coveted relief and
they're going to
give some of us back 1400 of our own
money
uh none they they like the power then
they give you
your money back and you go thank you
thank you
this is what we have to understand
palpatine got it
palpatine got it you create crises
to accumulate power and remember what he
said right before that
a little bit earlier in the movie he was
saying once this
uh once what was it once this disaster
no he went
once this crisis i think he says once
this crisis is abated
i will put down these emergency powers
that you will have given me
guess what he did he didn't put him down
and then about what was it about 20
years later
luke had to throw him into a pit then he
ended up coming back and then there was
some crappy movies about that but
you get my point the reason that they
don't put their power down is because if
you're in
politics you like power you like power
all right let's move on let's let's skip
that next one uh i already did star wars
enough star wars people
excuse me if you had to assign yourself
and your team to seinfeld characters who
would you be and why
um what geez uh
you know i think well i guess i would be
jerry in
that you know the idea of seinfeld was
there was this like crazy world with
this with these crazy characters and
jerry was just
trying to sort of stay sane in it like
he was using comedy to like relate to
the world in a way that made him
seem sane and they were just like a
bunch of odd characters in it
david absolutely loves elaine so i would
say david would be elaine
and i will be jerry um uh russell 44
says will there be a reuben meetup with
pets
i love this idea clyde would love to
meet people and often when i'm walking
clyde now clyde gets recognized more
than i do at this point cause i got a
freaking mask and
sunglasses and a hat and i look like i'm
about to rob a bank um so everybody
wants to meet clyde
we are doing a meet-up in orange county
in oc sometime soon i'm in touch with
chef andrew gruel
we're going to do it at one of his slap
fish locations we're trying to figure
out
all the specifics i got a little bit of
family visiting the next week or so
we're going to put this together
probably i would say in the next within
within the next month let's see and also
because you know things are opening up
so we'll be able to do things indoors
imagine
human beings gathering indoors to eat
food and drink
drink and laugh what a world what a
world indeed
the zone says what are a couple of your
non-negotiables
i like this question because i quickly
glanced at it and i was like well
depends which way you're asking me
non-negotiable so you mean just sort of
in
in life just like in life i would say
in terms of like the type of people i
like being around i'll do i'll do it
this way for you so
you know the last year has been pretty
bananas not only because
you know i released the book and the
show's gone well and all that kind of
stuff
but but building locals and getting into
the tech world like i'm spending
more time in that world now than i am in
this world in a certain way like i just
added another
another job and another career into the
mix of it and i can tell you this
when i've been fundraising when we've
been
talking to tech people i love people
who are doing things and just make
decisions and go with it for better or
worse now
you're going to make some mistakes along
the way when you do that but i can tell
you
we're in the midst of fundraising right
now and we'll we'll have some
announcements
by the end of the month i think in about
two weeks from now some like great stuff
is happening really really great stuff
and i wish i could tell you now but i
just can't
um but what i can tell you is when you
go into these meetings with people
people who have gajillion dollars and
you're telling them well this is why we
want to raise the money because we want
to put this much towards tech and we
want to put
this much towards customer acquisition
and all that stuff and by the way with
locals right now we have put
zero zero zero that's not a white
supremacy zero that's just a regular
zero
we put zero dollars into advertising
everything that we've done with locals
in essence has come from me and then
we've brought on great people like scott
adams
and greg gutfeld and tulsi gabbard and
then they promoted amongst their own
networks but we've really
you know we've done it in in many ways
in a reverse way than most big tech
companies do most big tech companies get
gajillion dollars
from huge vcs and then they just pour
money into everything we've
actually focused on building a good
product first
and now we're trying to raise money to
get it to the next level but what i can
tell you is this
i've been in meetings where there's a
lot of people they just want to hear
themselves talk they love meetings and
you're in zooms
with 18 boxes and heads and everybody's
just pontificating
what i like and i've had a few people
like this
that you get into a meeting with them
and it's like within a minute they're
like all right i'm in
what do you need what do you want to do
here's how i can help blah blah
like i like people with like vision and
that don't want to [ __ ] and just
make something happen
you know it's it's ironic i suppose at
some level like i'm so sick
of people just talking and i get that
i'm an interviewer and i talk for a
living
but like the talking about talking and
let's talk about the next meeting we're
gonna have and let's talk
about our feelings and all of these
things like i like people who do
not people who talk you can talk and
there's some value in it for sure
and free speech is important okay but i
like people who do
and i can't wait to just tell you all
about the things that we've got coming
because they're great uh chris says dave
as a fan of the golden girls what are
your thoughts on the one
season of the golden palace oh chris
it's a it was a disaster i actually once
went so
first off for those of you who who don't
remember this the golden girls was on
nbc
um for seven seasons and then when it
went off the air in may of 1992
then it was reborn as the golden palace
on
cbs in the fall of that year
bea arthur who played dorothy she left
and then it was the other
three ladies and then they added cheech
marin
uh as a chef and they entered don
cheadle as like the front the the hotel
manager and the golden palace was a
hotel and basically blanche
and rose and sofia ran a hotel uh there
was only one season of it
it's horrible it's it's so it's on
youtube
i've tried to watch it we still watch
golden girls all the time on sundays we
watch a couple episodes
golden palace it's just terrible i
actually once went to usc
and they were doing a little talk about
the golden girls and they had betty
white there
and a couple of the golden girls
creators and which
which guy was it tony thomas who was i
think one of the original producers
somebody asked him about the golden
palace and he goes uh that fakakta show
and it was just it was just a nightmare
they didn't know what they were doing
why did you have these old ladies
running a hotel and also
uh this sort of gets to the question
about seinfeld earlier
what a good sitcom needs is you need
like the same character sort of in the
middle
because then that lets all the crazy
people do all the crazy stuff
and and dorothy who is played by b
arthur who
references some classically liberal
principles in the uh golden girl show
she was sort of the center of the show
so once you removed her then you had
just a bunch of crazy people
you know you had the [ __ ] and the idiot
and the old lady but you were missing
like sort of the meat of the show so
golden palace was absolutely terrible
margot says are you going to adopt any
more critters ah there's been an ongoing
debate
in this house about getting another dog
now first off
as i said we're working on expanding the
family of humans first
so we're putting you know most of our
energy is there clyde
is a little nutty clyde he loves to jump
on people
uh he loves to chew literally anything
and everything we've had him trained a
little bit
turned out that the trainer was a social
justice warrior literally
the trainer you would not believe this
like i don't know how i
don't think i've mentioned this on the
show the trainer we get the trainer we
got clyde in around
april right like right as the lockdowns
were beginning so right about a year
from now maybe it was march even
and i think i've told this where uh i
heard that these
uh all the shelters we're gonna have to
put down the dogs and i just ran there
and we weren't ready to get a dog yet
because emma had just passed away i was
also supposed to be on a book tour we
wanted to take a break
probably not get a dog till the fall but
then i was like i'm just not going to
let
all these dogs be killed i saw clyde he
was they already had a paper sign he was
going to be killed later that day
grab clyde anyway we get him trained the
trainer then
who it was very obvious like we kind of
didn't see eye to eye on life
uh he decided his clyde's last week of
training which i guess is where they
teach them everything because he didn't
teach him that much in the few weeks
before
um he's like he called us one day and he
was like oh i i can't i'm not gonna
trade him anymore because i'm gonna be
spending my time going to the black
lives matter rallies
and the way he said it was like oh yeah
yeah like like i was supposed to be like
oh you're such a great person you're not
going to do your job
anymore and go ahead and do that because
that that's more important
anywho um clyde is nutty and he's got a
ton of energy and he's part boxer and
boxers are known
for just endless energy and you know
boxers are known also because they're
always punching right boxers are always
doing this
so he jumps so every time i enter the
house he jumps
and then he tries to punch my balls so
he's always going after the balls
it's a height thing i don't know if it's
directly to the balls but but so i've
been kicked
and punched in the nuts a lot over the
last year
more than the average person for sure
and uh we got to deal with that so maybe
we'll get another dog
you know we'll see kevin says my
brother-in-law
thinks that the insanely woke cancel
culture storm is just a blip
and insists there are simply too many
regular people in america who merely
want the left
who merely want to be left alone to live
their lives and follow their dreams
for the storm to continue i want to
believe him but should i
um i think he's right at some level and
wrong at some level so i think he's
right in that i think 80 percent of
americans are live and let live
i think the vast majority of us um
are okay having some political
differences i think most people don't
care what you do in your bedroom i think
most people
if you if you act decently and honestly
i think most people want to let you live
your life and that's just great and
that's the way it's always been
the flaw in that argument is that there
is an
ever-growing brainwashed group of young
people
and really bad people up top the leaders
of blm of antifa
the progressive movement who want to get
into
every part of your life and this is the
challenge
this is the challenge for anyone that's
liberty minded in any way
i just want to live and let live i just
want to own what i own i want to live my
life and i don't care what you do
well okay that's great if the other guy
is willing to agree to that but if the
other guy is always but i want more of
your stuff
i want to tell you more how to live i
want to indoctrinate your children
all of these things well now we got an
asymmetry here that needs to be dealt
with so the problem is
that even though he's right that most
people
most regular people his words most
regular people want to be left alone
if you've got this ever moving monster
this mob that is looking to destroy all
of our past destroy all of our art and
comedy and cartoons
and history and take down monuments and
all that stuff well then
our our sort of live and let live
attitude isn't the thing that's going to
stop it so the thing that's going to
stop it is we all got to get braver and
speak up about it
so i think he's i think he's right and
wrong and hopefully he's willing to get
in the game as well because just sitting
there quietly
ain't gonna fix it char says dave do you
actually have time in your schedule to
read any of the books you refer to on
your show
or do you have your team summarize i
have six or seven books in my queue
daily
and i barely have 20 minutes including
don't burn this book much less time to
write your next book you must be
superman if so
um so i'll be totally honest with you
when i started the interview show
five six years ago i used to read every
single book
like cover to cover and that's how i
would conduct every interview
i can't do that anymore i simply don't
have the time not only am i i'm working
on my second book now
but locals as i said has sort of taken
over my life
we've got so much more going on here
we've got several businesses and
employees i also have to be able to
enjoy life you know i i love what i'm
doing but i mean i also have to be able
to take a break every now and again and
everything else
and can't be like just constantly
running on more political stuff more
political stuff etc
so i don't read all the books you know
as an interviewer i would say
sometimes you want to read everything in
the book and sometimes you don't i think
sometimes knowing a little bit
less is better so for example the
interview that i did with jordan
peterson two weeks ago
about beyond order you know he's got
he's got 12 more rules in there i
i did not well first off i only got the
book a day before
um so timing wise was going to be tough
but i felt you know if i go in with a
little bit less because i know jordan so
well
so i know a little bit about each of
these 12 topics and then i can sort of
just hand it to him
to to curate everything that goes on in
those chapters i felt that was the best
way to do it
sometimes you really want to know more
so every now and again
i'll read a couple chapters sometimes
i'll read the full book
sometimes i don't really have a chance
to read much of anything and michael
will
will summarize it for me it's a mix of
everything
and i try to do it i try to do it in a
responsible enough way that i know
enough
um but you know i would say that that
you know
most interviewers probably don't read
any of the stuff
uh and the amount of books trust me if
you one day we should just give away a
ton of books right we have
we have so many books so many people
send us books multiple copies of books i
do give books away
to the local library and things we have
so many books here maybe one day we'll
just do like a big giveaway on the
locals community and just i have signed
copies of a gajillion things and
i just don't have room for everything
storm says non-political who was your
favorite transformer
mine was generation one optimus prime
and my brothers was generation one sound
wave
well storm i've got
generation one sound wave this is my
sound wave from childhood right here
i'm gonna transform him right in front
of you because i still can do it without
a flaw now i do have to show you one
thing
his head has disconnected from his body
so i'm going to here's
sound waves head i'm just going to put
that down for just a moment i'm going to
transform sound wave look his
he's a little as i said he's old this is
from like 84 85
his uh his little cassette just popped
open there uh we are going to transform
sound wave obviously you get the legs
out first you bust out the feet
you're going to take out the arms you're
going to get the hands down
okay and then there you go and now
you've got
you've got sound wave right there that's
his head i should glue that back on we
should glue soundwave's head on here
i'll just hold that right there
there is sound wave for you and if you
press the button and it's not working as
well because it's a little busted
you're gonna open up the cassette player
and who do we have here
that's right we've got ravage the
panther
okay so yes soundwave was my favorite i
also loved starscream
uh who was the plane obviously and he
was always getting into a fight with
megatron
and he was voiced by the same guy who
voiced
cobra commander in the gi joe cartoon oh
and as long as i'm busting out cartoons
and speaking of gi joe
i've got my old school uh storm shadow
right here as you can see
as what happened with most transformers
of the day his crotch is completely
blown out it was just a
design flaw yeah i mean he was having a
good time but it was just a
design flaw in the in the toys and i've
got my original
boba fett right here that is the
original
boba fett when michael saw this uh he
started freaking out because apparently
there is a boba fett that you could have
got around
probably 1982 or so that the rocket
there was a button and the rocket would
actually shoot out and that thing's
worth like 10 grand right now this is
just regular
old boba fett so there's boba fett
and he hangs out with storm shadow and
uh
and ravage and sound wave in a little
box and it's and it's on set by the way
we keep it we keep it right over there
all right people i think we did a little
bit of everything we did some politics
we did some family life we did some
culture and some tv
it was a wide swath of information today
hope you enjoyed it by the way a lot of
people commented you know i was a little
i was a little dour yesterday i was a
little sort of more
agitated than usual and i felt kind of
weird like
the show wrapped and i was like man like
is this [ __ ] getting to me
and you know usually and i think
probably one of the main reasons you
guys come to me for this stuff is that i
don't leave you feeling worse and i do
try to put a positive spin on some of
this stuff and
i don't think politics is everything so
i do think we will be okay and all of
that stuff and i think this is just the
story of humans
that has been told a million times
before and will be told a million times
again
and it's a headache now because of
social media and everything else
um but i was like kind of banged up
after the show yesterday i was just like
man just one
stupid story after the other and they're
just destroying everything and there's
just so much crap
all the time and then i did jump in the
comments and i was reading what
everybody said on locals and it was like
a lot of you sort of
appreciated the the honesty in it that
you know
for as as sort of pleasant as i can
deliver some of this stuff that you know
i'm just a human too so
uh i appreciate your uh feelings about
my feelings
um i'm having an illegal dinner party
tonight don't tell anybody
uh if you wanna perhaps see some insider
pictures join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh part two of my interview with fox
news host dana perrino
is up on youtube right now and the full
episode is already up ad free
over on locals oh and tomorrow we're
doing a friday panel because it's friday
and that's what we do on fridays the
friday panel
because it would be odd if we did the
friday panel on wednesdays and we're
going to be talking about covid and just
general health because you know one of
the things is we're now finding out that
body mass
index and obesity and diabetes and a
bunch of other
health issues and co-morbidities had far
more to do with the people that died
with covid than just covid itself
uh so we're gonna have three people on
to discuss max lugavir who's been on the
show before gina florio and dr
j barachar baracharya
will all be on the show i will promise
to pronounce his name better tomorrow
once we have him on the show
and we're going to sort of unpack what
some of the actual science is behind
some of this stuff and i'm sure we'll
talk about lockdowns and the rest of it
uh okay i got a hectic day so enjoy it
everybody
get out there have fun be free
and i'll see you tomorrow
you